connaissez-vous la tragique histoire de
jeanne de belleville ce n'est pas le
genre d'histoire qu'on trouve dans les
manuels scolaires
bon j'en abuse un peu il ya des pages
sur les femmes parfois pour vous situer
un petit peu le contexte avant de
présenter le personnage on se trouve
dans les années 1300 40
à cette époque il existe une guerre de
succession au niveau du duché de
bretagne avec d'un côté charles de blois
qui est soutenue par le roi de france
philippe 6 et de l'autre côté jean de
montfort qui est soutenue par le roi
d'angleterre edouard iii pour essayer de
mettre fin à cette guerre de succession
la trêve de malestroit est signée en
1343 et elle a un peu donc un statu quo
entre les deux camps mais on craint
toujours une invasion anglaise à cette
époque là le roi de france philippe 6
donc est aussi affaibli financièrement
et militairement et même le fait de dire
qu'il est la nation française ne suffit
pas à le consoler jeanne de belleville
dans tout ça pour en revenir au
personnage est né vers 1300 elle est la
fille de maurice 4 de montaigu qui est
senior de belleville et de palluau et de
les tees de parthenay sa mère elle est
mariée la première fois à l'âge de 12
ans avec geoffroy châteaubriant il reste
marier ensemble jusqu'à ses 26 ans et
ils ont une fille elle est ensuite marié
brièvement à guide penthièvre mais le
mariage est vite annulée pendant tout ce
temps ça faisait déjà longtemps qu'elle
avait rencontré olivier 4 de clisson qui
est content qu'ils étaient mariés aussi
à ce moment là ils ont donc le liaison
ensemble pen fille isabelle qui meurt en
bas âge et finissent par se marier est
donc là c'est vraiment un mariage
d'amour
ce troisième mariage et ensemble ils ont
quatre enfants
jane morris qui meurt en bas âge olivier
et guillaume et donc son mari olivier de
clisson lui laisse une grande autonomie
elle administre mm ces différents
domaines à noirmoutier à assured il dieu
et elle agit aussi pour essayer de
limiter la violence sexuelle sur ses
terres notamment en encourageant la
création de bordel à nantes ce qu'elle
pense que favoriser la prostitution
permet d'éviter les débordements de ce
monsieur pour terminer de cerner
personnage elle est apparemment très
belle mince assez sportive elle pratique
beaucoup d'activités physiques
apparemment la peau plus tomates les
cheveux châtains et des yeux verts elle
est généralement décrite comme bell à
tel point que le roi serait jaloux de ce
couple qui a l'air heureux est beau et
aussi jaloux de leur propriété parce
qu'ensemble et possède à peu près
la loire atlantique actuel philippe 6
l'accusent donc olivier de clisson de
s'être allié avec le roi d'angleterre
toujours dans cette histoire de lutte
pour la possession du duché de bourgogne
il n'accuse donc de soutenir jean de
montfort le prétendant qui était
soutenue par le roi d'angleterre pendant
l'été 1343 olivier de clisson est invité
par le roi de france au mariage de son
fils et il est invité à participer au
tournoi ce qui est un honneur donc il se
sent flatté et tenté d'accepter sa femme
le met pourtant en garde
mais il a aussi envie de participer
parce qu'il a pour ambition de devenir
connétable de france et pour ça il est
important de se faire bien voir
donc ils pensent que ce tournoi pourrait
lui permettre d'accéder à ce but
malheureusement peu après son départ
pour paris jeanne de belleville reçoit
la visite de raul de la bière inières
qui lui explique que son mari a été
capturé par le roi ainsi que les 14
chevallier qui l'accompagnent il est
d'abord emprisonné sans raison puis le
prévôt de paris lui rend visite le 2
août 1343 pour lui lire sa condamnation
à mort pour félonie et entente avec
l'ennemi il est condamné à avoir la tête
décoller en place des halles puis à être
pendue au jubé de montfaucon
comme il est noble il a quand même le
droit de garder ses vêtements qui est
pas mal
enfin bref sa tête est aussi envoyé à
nantes pourrait être exposé sur les
remparts jeanne de belleville forcément
est un peu abattu mais elle se reprend
très vite et surtout elle est en rage et
elle est très en colère
déclare que dès à présent ma
détermination et mon courage sont sans
borne et pour marquer le coup elle
décide de se rendre à nantes avec ses
deux garçons olivier guillaume pour leur
montrer la tête de son père sur les
remparts charmant et elle parvient aussi
à récupérer ladite tête en la faisant
échanger contre une autre son but est de
continuer le rêve de son mari d'avoir
une bretagne le plus indépendant
possible du royaume de france
elle se rend compte d'abord auprès de la
femme de jean de montfort donc pour
rappel jean montfort c'était le
prétendant au duché de bourgogne soutenu
par les anglais j'en doute fort est
prisonnier du roi de france depuis trois
ans mais sa femme se trouve au château
d'ypres et c'est là que j'aime de
belleville la rencontre elle lui demande
son soutien pour les actions qu'elle
compte mener par la suite désormais à ne
s'occupe plus de l'intendance de ses
terres elle s'habille en homme et elle
se destine à la guerre elle constituer
un host une armée en faisant tour des
châteaux qu'elle possède pour rassembler
le plus d'hommes d'un possible et elle
arrive assez facilement à se rallier des
chevaliers
puis des marins par la suite ça peut
sembler étonnant une femme qui mène des
troupes mais déjà à l'est du pays
elle sait naviguer quand on verra par la
suite qu'elle se rend sur mer donc ça
lui donne une certaine autorité
naturelle et aussi les hommes la
rejoigne par solidarité avec son mari
qui a été tué et qui était un seigneur
et mais dans le pays et elle était belle
aussi
ça peut jouer à la mi septembre elle a
déjà 4000 hommes autour d'elle et elle
fait la tournée des châteaux qui
appartiennent au roi de france pour les
piquer elle tue beaucoup de personnes
elle emmène aussi dans ses escapades ses
deux garçons qui ont à l'époque 7 et 4
ans et donc tous ces pillages nuisent
beaucoup au roi philippe qui ne peut pas
intervenir parce que sinon ça après la
trêve de malestroit et donc le roi
d'angleterre pourrait intervenir à son
tour donc il est un petit peu bloqué à
ce moment là il décide en contrepartie
de confisquer les biens le gène de
belleville et de la bannière de ses
terres ensuite à chaque fois qu'elle
commet une exaction dans un château ou
une ville qui appartiennent au roi de
france
il exécute en échange des bananeraies de
jeanne de belleville est donc cette
situation arrive rapidement à un blocage
et il faut qu'elle trouve un autre moyen
de manifester son mécontentement
et c'est là qu'on arrive à la deuxième
partie j'aime de belleville pirates
l'idée ne lui est sûrement pas apparu de
nulle part déjà son mari pratiquer la
navigation et a pu lui raconter ses
expériences de voyage comme je les dis
elle savait naviguer elle a aussi pu
être inspiré par le récit de la
princesse al field c'était une princesse
danoise du 9ème siècle qui devait subir
un mariage arrangé avec le prince de
norvège
elle refuse prend la mer et met à feu et
à sang la mer du nord pour montrer
qu'elle n'est pas d'accord et jeanne de
belleville posséder un exemplaire du
manuscrit le l'histoire de la princesse
anne field qui lui avait offert par son
mari donc a pu l'inspirer
elle se procure son premier navire en
vendant ces objets et ses bijoux
et en rachetant auprès d'un armateur et
elle décide de l'appeler ma vengeance
s'impose le ton par la suite elle
acquiert deux autres navires auprès de
la flotte d'angleterre et elle embarque
avec elle une centaine d'hommes
chevallier et marin est également ses
deux enfants qui ont toujours 7 et 4 ans
je m'appelle et une chèvre
parce que la nourrice des enfants on
refuse de monter à bord étonnamment donc
il faut bien pouvoir nourrir ses deux
enfants elle cerne donc la terreur le
long des côtes
mais ça lui suffit pas parce que quand
elle attaque un bateau ça se voit moins
que le brûler un château ça se passe en
mer donc c'est pas assez impressionnant
elle décide donc plutôt que de brûler
les navires après les avoir attaqués de
les laisser dériver
après avoir pendu l'équipage au gréement
et oumma ça en jette un petit peu plus
elle prend aussi couramment raul de la
guérinière celui qui était venu lui
annoncer la mort de son mari
mais il est rapidement tu es bon elle
même ne souhaitait pas énormément on
sait qu'elle s'est battue à une occasion
lors de la prise de la forteresse de
lannion pour le reste elle se contentait
probablement plutôt de donner des ordres
le roi de france finit quand même par
réagir entre-temps engins de david est
devenu célèbre on l'appelle à petit
grâce bretonne où la lionne sanglante et
il met donc fin à la trève de malestroit
en intervenant pour arrêter jeunes de
belgique au moment où ils réagissent à
fait quand même à peu près un an que ça
dure
et puisque ça fait un an que jeanne et
sur terre puis en mer a massacré des
français elle commence à en avoir un
petit peu marre aussi aimerait rentrer
chez elle et offrir une vie un petit peu
plus normale à ses garçons elle convainc
donc jeanne de montfort toujours la
femme de jean de montfort de laisser
charles de blois arrivé au trône du cal
de bretagne parce qu'elle espère que du
coup c'est adoucira un petit peu roi de
france c'est que cela permettra
peut-être de faire libérer jean de
montfort malheureusement au même moment
alors qu'elles voudraient rentrer au
pays
elle est poursuivie par le roi de france
qui comme je le disais a décidé
d'intervenir et elle a donc six navires
lancé à ses troupes
et il ya une tempête en plus de ça donc
elle ne peut pas s'approcher trop près
des côtes parce qu'elle risquerait de se
prendre des rochers de faire naufrage
et elle ne peut pas non plus aller trop
large parce que du coup elle risquerait
d'être attaqué par les navires français
elle est piégée et a fini par faire
naufrage à ce moment là elle met à la
mer les deux chaloupes qu'il y reste
la première chaloupe se brise en
atteignant la mer et dans la deuxième
chaloupe elle parvient à monter avec
quelques hommes et avec ses deux garçons
ils sont à la dérive
ils n'ont rien à manger les harcèlements
à boire un peu avec la pluie enfin bref
elles se retrouvent dans une situation
vraiment critique par rapport à là où
elle a commencé et elle dérive pendant
six jours à cette époque en plus la mère
faisait peur plus qu'aujourd'hui c'était
pas vraiment un environnement auquel on
avait envie de se confronter tout comme
la montagne et donc se retrouver en
pleine tempête à devoir mettre une
chaloupe à la mer et des faire descendre
les enfants dans des filets c'était
vraiment une situation critique et son
plus jeune fils guillaume meurt au
quatrième jour et elle est obligée de le
jeter à la mer
finalement elle atteint la cote ce
niveau de l'âge et de morlaix sans
savoir au moment où elle accoste si
cette ville est plutôt côté anglais
breton ou côté français par chance à le
feu se faire enseigner par ces gens et
elle apprend que cette vide et bonfoh
risque donc du côté de jean de montfort
elle parvient à rejoindre jeanne de
montfort et ensemble elles décident le
tout pour le tout d'aller faire évader
jean de montfort bonjour bonsoir été
emprisonnés comme j'ai dit depuis
maintenant quatre ans plus tôt dans de
bonnes conditions il était au louvre il
était bien traitée ce que le roi site
sans faire un maillot en tout cas à
l'évasion réussie
jean montfort se déguise en marchant et
part pour l'angleterre peau rejoindre le
roi et se battre contre les français
malheureusement été tués peu de temps
après et donc pour terminer cette
histoire
j'aime de belleville jeanne de montfort
et les enfants de gênes de béziers
partie à leur tour pour l'angleterre
pour se mettre sous la protection
d'edouard iii
enfin et effectivement edouard iii les
accueillent les deux enfants de jeunes
de béziers sont élevées à la cour
d'angleterre pour rappel les deux
enfants qui lui restait et et jeanne sa
fille aînée et olivier est apparemment
olivier à ses proches du roi et devient
chevalier
ironiquement olivier devient également
connétable de france sous le roi charles
vi
le rôle que son père aurait aimé
endosser me auxquels n'a pas pu accéder
il possède un hôtel de clisson à paris
etc enfin bref sont pas très rancuniers
les français jeanne de belleville de son
côté épousa un anglais où elle termine t
qui était chevalier entre 1343 et d'une
349 et elle meurt en 1359 après une vie
bien remplie donc souvent jeanne de
belleville et écrite comme une femme
pirate
effectivement elle a pratiqué la
piraterie n'est pas dans un but de se
procurer des richesses même si elles
s'approprier la cargaison des bateaux
qu'elle a qu'à l'attaqué mais son but
était vraiment la vengeance comme
l'indiquent le nom de son bateau et ses
accents piraterie n'ont duré que le
temps de cette vengeance
elle s'en est plutôt bien sorti au final
malgré une vie bien mouvementée et
j'espère donc le récit de sa vie vous a
intéressé pour la prochaine fois je sais
pas quand je le ferai une gente dame la
dass mais il ya un épisode de chroniques
de profs qui se prépare et qui sortira
en février et sachez que le tournage de
cet épisode aujourd'hui a été
interrompue sans vous voyez grâce à la
magie du montage parce qu'on va livrer
mon éclairage donc le prochain kronig le
prof sera magnifiquement éclairés et
donc en attendant revoir